So welcome back!
You just made it to one of the hairy parts of this class when we talk about normal distributions.
Now we've come back into something intuitive, which is how to manipulate normal distributions.
Like I said in the previous class, you can flip coins up to better to the values
from the normal distribution just the same way you flip coins.
So now I'd like to understand what happens if I manipulate normal distributions.
So my very first example will be the following.
Suppose all the salaries in my company Udacity are normally distributed.
That is to say, If I were to look at the salaries, there is a well-defined mean of course.
Fewer and fewer people deviate from the mean by a larger amount where the frequency of deviations
captured really well by this normal distributions as most people are really near the mean
and there's a small number of people are farther from mean.
And just for the sake of the argument, suppose the mean is $60,000 per year
and the standard deviation is 10,000--these are obviously not accurate numbers.
Suppose now, I give everyone a raise of say $10,000, what do think is the new mean
and the new standard deviation following µ' and σ'--can you answer these questions?